so I'm sure it was probably like your
reaction Dave when you first see this
pop-up on Twitter people are going yo
nothing you'll be happy and it's
associated with the world economic forum
is there eight predictions for the world
in 2030 it's from their Global Futures
Council and people are passing it around
and usually when I see something like
that I'm like you know the Waf that's
the world's business Elite it's the
political Elite they couldn't possibly
be predicting the end of private
property right like that doesn't make
sense so you go and you do a little
extra research and it doesn't take very
much to find their video that's right on
their Twitter stream you can access it
today that does as you said show that
that handsome young man you'll know
nothing you'll be happy at number one
with by the way seven other really crazy
uh predictions as well number two is
that the US will no longer be the
leading superpower but for whatever
reason nobody got far enough to number
two to be freaked out about that we were
all too busy eating bugs to get to
number two we talk about that a little
bit in the book but if you think about
it you know somebody who's helped people
you create wealth and generate wealth
for over 25 years I know that wealth
comes from ownership you have to have
assets that have the opportunity to
retain value or appreciate and value so
the idea that the global Elite don't
want you to have private property is
incredibly scary about especially since
throughout history the people who didn't
have property were unfree unhappy and
probably not alive
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
recovering investment banker an
entrepreneur and author of the new book
you will own nothing your war with a new
Financial world order and how to fight
back Carol Roth Carol we have crossed
paths many times but you've never been
on the Reuben report welcome
thank you it's so great to finally be
here I feel like you know I've watched
so many of them I've like put myself
into the show so many times but it's
nice to actually have the conversation
our friend uh Bridget gave us the
Bridget fantasy connected us like right
before I moved from Los Angeles and I've
pretty much washed my hands of that
entire Coast at this point but I'm
letting you back in the uh in the circle
over here in the right just because of
Bridget's so awesome so I appreciate the
uh making the exception for me all right
well I want to dive into the book
because you're you're hitting in this
book between centralized currencies and
ESG and woe corporations oh you're
hitting so many of the things uh that I
talk about on a political level every
day uh you're talking about in this book
here but real quick for the people that
do not know you can you give me Carol
Roth 101 in about one to two minutes and
then we will dive into the meat
yes so I came from a blue color
background neither of my parents went to
college my dad was an electrician and I
had the opportunity to go to a fabulous
school and to take on a lot of dead and
my dad said if you're going to take on a
lot of debt you have to pay it down
quickly so that led me into Investment
Banking and obviously never wanted to be
the world's best investment banker I
really just wanted to be a game show
host but along the way I've collected
lots of experiences wait did you really
want to be a game show host I still do
Dave I really do yeah what was who was
it was it Bob Barker was it John Eubanks
who was it I mean I really like the
Steve Harvey approach where it's sort of
like a comedy show where you can kind of
banter and play and do the Improv
because that was one of the things that
I've done in collecting my experience is
actually trained with Second City for a
little while in Chicago uh but I am the
sort of collector of experiences but
sort of the the through line is that
I've always advocated for the little guy
the average American the creation of
wealth because I was so fortunate to
have that opportunity to seize the
American dream and we see it shifting so
much since my time you know helping
companies raise money and do mergers and
Acquisitions and the like
um that uh you know it's really
frustrating to me to see it moving the
other direction
so one of the things I've been talking
about on the show a lot when I when I
bring up ESG and all of this stuff is
that it's it's a real combination of
government and corporate power that is
kind of crashing down on everyone at the
moment which is why wokism seems to be
everywhere it maybe isn't in your
day-to-day but it's just being hit with
at the bank and at the store and when
you turn on Netflix and everything else
can you just kind of give me a beginning
of when all this woke craziness kind of
leaked into the system
well you kind of have to go back you
know I tie the the woke ISM into ESG and
which I'm sure that you do on a regular
basis as well and I kind of think about
that as business social credit you've
got a bunch of people who are sitting
around going you know they've got these
companies and their shareholders you
know want them to do certain things they
want them to to benefit them for taking
the risk their board of directors have a
fiduciary duty to do what's right for
the shareholders so what can we do to
manipulate these companies and to bully
them to hold them hostage into doing the
things that we want them to do and
really this started you know decades and
decades ago with the UN and I would even
offer that it started back in 1971 when
Klaus Schwab of the world economic Forum
um first called it uh the European
management Forum before then and brought
out the idea of stakeholders and
stakeholder capitalism which are these
weasel words that really stand in
opposition to ownership you know if you
think about what a shareholder is
there's somebody who has gotten a piece
of the business they're either their
Blood Sweat and Tears or taking on risk
and making an investment and so they've
got skin in the game and it makes sense
that the businesses run for their
benefit stakeholders can be anyone you
know I could come up and go I'm a
stakeholder and it means nothing you're
not related to the business the free
market kind of sorts out all these other
things that they're talking about so it
really is an opportunity to hold these
businesses hostage and the language that
they use which is is so interesting are
these weasel Wars and weasel phrases
that don't mean anything like I can't
actually Define ESG other than the
acronym for you because they change what
ESG stands for based on their whims and
objectives I mean the fact that Elon
Musk who you know has a green vehicle
company was kicked out of the S P 500
ESG index because he bought Twitter and
they were worried about his you know
Free Speech stance but they left Exxon
Mobil in just kind of goes to show you
that this is very fungible based on
whoever's on the inside making that
decision so the basics though are that
generally you want your ESG score to be
high so that you will have access to
more credit and I guess new markets and
things like that as a corporation and
when people are talking about well what
do you have to do to get that high score
you have to have these crazy diversity
equity and inclusion departments you
have to have a climate policy all of
these things that in most cases probably
have absolutely nothing to do with the
core competency or purpose of the
corporation in the first place right
yeah it's taking the eye off the ball
for the corporation so if you're a
shareholder you're losing out because
your CEO and management team is no
longer entirely focused on driving value
for you as a shareholder they're trying
to you know play this like gamified
system to figure out how they can get a
score up or at least not have it sink
down so low that they're no longer able
to access the capital markets at the
same time you have these companies like
BlackRock which is the largest asset
manager in the world who's basically
using your Capital they're representing
a pension fund retirement fund and it's
your Capital that's being used to bully
the companies and you don't have the say
in it so you as an individual's
shareholder somebody who's trying to
have your wealth increased is getting
hit twice and oh by the way it there's
also kind of a profiteering aspect to
this I mean part of the reason ESG is so
entrenched is that there's a huge
profiteering infrastructure sure so
whether you're a fund that has an
exchange traded fund or an ETF that
maybe is a very low margin business you
know now you can slap ESG on it and you
can charge a higher percentage rate for
that ETF or if you're an accountant or a
consultant or whatnot you know you need
to help these companies figure out how
they can get their better ESG score so
there's this financial scam piece on one
side from a profiteering standpoint in
the financial scam piece in terms of
hurting your wealth and overall you know
it's not good uh really on on any of
those points so to connect this to the
politics of the day for some of the
people that might be missing some of
this when you see Bud Light do a
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney this is
in essence because of ESG when you see
Target put those uh the tucking close in
that they know no one's gonna buy it's
because they want to maintain that high
score do you know of any instances where
shareholders have actually sued the
board or sued the companies because
they're basically not doing their
fiduciary responsibility as opposed to
doing a this responsibility to the
social credit gods
we haven't seen it yet at a shareholder
level you know whether that's directly
to the companies or to the Pension funds
or whatnot but we have seen it at the
state level you know whether it's
Governors or attorney generals or
treasury treasurers or whatnot have all
been pushing back and basically saying
you need to drop this nonsense and if
you don't then you can't do business
with our state what that has done and
this is probably not entirely surprising
is you have people like Larry Fink who's
the CEO of BlackRock who's Big mad that
we figured this out and so he says I'm
not going to say ESG anymore because
it's been politicized but guess what it
wasn't you saying it it's not the
letters it's the issue is the underlying
action so if you change the name to
impact investing or sustainable
investing or whatever it is it's still
the same underlying issue is there any
company that has been more outwardly
affected by ESG than Disney in terms of
what they create and just sort of like
the craziness around it you know all the
leaked videos that Chris Ruffo put out
where the employees basically saying
they're putting their secret gay agenda
and they want more asexual characters
and just like the just like the Litany
of craziness that has nothing to do with
creating good stories or ultimately
making profit for the people that own
stock in Disney
so I'm a financial person so I tend to
view everything through a financial lens
and a little bit less through the
cultural loves I would say the the
companies that have been most impacted
by it are the fossil fuel companies and
obviously we have been paying the price
quite literally for a long time from it
because what has happened is that it
they've directed you know billions and
billions of dollars that are really
needed in terms of investment in fossil
fuels away from that industry which
means that we are less economically
secure today and in the future not just
directly for something like oil but the
6 000 derivative Products that come from
it as well as all the transportation
that happens from it and that just kind
of goes to show you this this is almost
like a mafia-esque operation right is
that we're going to use our muscle and
you're either with us or against us you
know Dave one of the things I did and
you will owe nothing is I really tried
to take the conspiracy element out of
this and the politicization out of this
because I do think that this starts
getting into this cam camp or this Camp
when you go to Blackrock shareholder
letter and you see them say these things
in their own words hey you know we're
going to be inclined to vote against
directors who don't you know follow what
we're saying on the environment or this
or that you know it's basically putting
out there you're either with us or
you're against us and that is going to
cost you and I find it that to be very
impactful but what are the interesting
things especially with these Financial
companies is all the ones who say that
they're ESG and remember that s is a
social piece they have no problem in
terms of investing in Wall Street
companies that help take away your home
from you so now you've got corporations
that have come in to compete in the
sandal Family Home Market and socially
somehow they think it's fine to rent you
the American dream and take that wealth
creation opportunity I'm not sure how
that plays into their their pitch that
their care about you know being a good
social company
can you we could do like five hours on
ESG obviously but I want I want to get
to a couple of the other topics here can
you just quickly so that I love the
title of the book and I I really love
the the cover of the book because the
words that are crossed out are so it was
the title of the book is you will own
nothing but the words that are crossed
out are it would have read you will own
a house a car a business stocks your
life so you can see those words blocked
out because that was the American dream
and now they're leading us to you will
own nothing can you talk about that line
you will own nothing because it does get
us to that conspiracy part of the wef
and that promo video that they put out
and that young kid owning nothing but
he's smiling and probably not living a
great life as he's eating bugs in the
future
really like your reaction Dave when you
first see this pop up on Twitter people
are going you'll owe nothing you'll be
happy and it's associated with the world
economic forum is there eight
predictions for the world in 2030 it's
from their Global Futures Council and
people are passing it around and usually
when I see something like that I'm like
you know the Waf that's the world's
business Elite it's the political Elite
they couldn't possibly be predicting the
end of private property right like that
doesn't make sense so you go and you do
a little extra research and it doesn't
take very much to find their video
that's right on their Twitter stream you
can access it today that does as you
said show that that has some young man
you'll know nothing you'll be happy at
number one with by the way seven other
really crazy uh predictions as well
number two is that the US will no longer
be the leading superpower but for
whatever reason nobody got far enough to
number two to be freaked out about that
we were all too busy eating bugs to get
to number two yeah so we talk about
book but if you think about you know
somebody who's helped people you create
wealth and generate wealth for over 25
years I know that wealth comes from
ownership you have to have assets that
have the opportunity to retain value or
appreciate and value so the idea that
the global Elite don't want you to have
private property is incredibly scary
it's about especially since throughout
history the people who didn't have
property were unfree unhappy and
probably not alive and if you think
about just that phrase you'll owe
nothing there's two really interesting
sort of psychological elements to it one
is that you will own nothing is that we
yeah they're doing it right they're fine
they're going to be great so it's not
Willow nothing or All or Nothing you
will owe nothing and then you'll be
happy and I think that as the Global
Financial Stakes you know continue to
shift we're obviously very late stage in
the US's Financial cycle as these sort
of uh middle of the Global Financial
Empire and these Elites start to see
that they're really concerned they're
jocking to control every resource
because they want to stay in power and
they want to keep the wealth so if they
get you to buy into the concept that you
are happy about this it makes it a lot
easier if you think it's great to rent
the American dream instead of own the
American dream because you know you
don't want to call the plumber or
whatever reason and take away that
number one asset on balance sheets
across households in the U.S it just
makes it easier they don't have to do
this by force it's like hey you bought
in you wanted you wanted a good life
you're going to be happy
uh you mentioned the the late stage
situation that we might be in as sort of
the center of the financial world is
there any way do you think any way out
of that I mean it seems to me for all
our faults if we're not the center of
most of what goes on on this planet that
it's going to be someone worse the
chances that it's going to be someone
better and maybe that's already been
outsourced and maybe the globalists
already have us for all we know uh but
do you see a way out actually
so it's a really scary proposition what
you said is incredibly insightful
because you know as the British stepped
into The Dutch's position and the U.S
stepped into the British position there
was always sort of an improvement you
know more of a Bastion of protection of
property rights and opportunity of free
markets and you look at the groups that
are waiting in the wings that we kind of
want to step into the US's position and
it's frightening right they're
tyrannical and dictatorial so this idea
of trying to salvage the current world
order and doing it for our own benefit
as well as you know the The Heirs coming
up behind us as well as the benefit of
the world is really important I do think
there are things that we can do to at
least delay it right in history there's
always a shift but could we delay it 50
or 100 years absolutely but the question
is will anybody who has the ability to
do that have the fortitude to do so you
have a Federal Reserve that hasn't held
the currency stable either for the good
of the world or for the United States
which is pretty incredible usually it's
one or the other a trade-off they've
managed to do both could we remove some
of the fed's powers and get stability
absolutely we could do that could we
stop our government from weaponizing the
dollar I mean we had the Biden
Administration freeze Russia's access to
its reserves you know who's going to
allow the U.S to be the the global
Reserve currency if you can't access the
reserves that the US's whim in our own
house we have a 125 percent debt to GDP
on a public basis could we make some
reforms and just bring our spending back
to 2018 or 2019 levels I'm not even
talking about like rolling back to 2010
just a few years before covid could we
do that run a surplus and start to pay
down our debt so that we weren't in such
a desperate situation and the government
didn't make such these bad decisions we
absolutely could do all of those things
but I think you and I both understand
the reality and the likelihood given you
know the the political leaders that we
have of that that happening so what's
important and one of the key reasons why
I wrote the book and tied this all
together is that you have to prepare
because we don't know the duration this
could be 12 months this could be 12
years this could be 50 years but it's
kind of like your house like you don't
have your Escape Plan and buy insurance
for a fire the day that you see the fire
you know in the Attic you have to
prepare ahead of time for that so you
don't want to be caught if the the
Global Financial order shifts and
there's certainly enough you know
non-conspiratorial clear data points and
signposts for this that you've thought
through all of these different elements
and come up with a plan so that you're
not the one stop you know kind of
standing there going what's happening to
me all right so I definitely want to
spend the last few minutes talking about
some of those Solutions and some of the
ways you can prepare but I wonder do you
do you find that the political parties
are equally at fault here like to me
almost everything you're describing is
completely in lockstep with virtually
everything the Democrats want now plenty
of Republicans end up voting for this
stuff but at at least there is some
pushback certainly here in Florida we
have gotten ESG out of all of our
government institutions obviously the
woke stuff Disney blah blah blah there
are some other Republican Governors
doing some things you hear Rand Paul and
Ted Cruz talking about this stuff but do
you think even the Republicans are sort
of useless for the most part when it
comes to this or do you think that my
commentary on the Democrats was fair
so I always sort of liken it to playing
a game you know the Democrats are the
kids who you know when they're losing
the game they just change the rules and
make them up as they go along where the
Republicans tell you how good they are
playing the game and then when you play
them they actually suck so you know the
ideas really do come
um in many cases from the Democratic
side of the aisle you know the things
like modern monetary Theory and the
overspending and whatnot but when the
Republicans have the opportunity to step
in and change things they never really
do on a financial standpoint I mean just
look at this fight that we had over the
debt ceiling where we had some really
serious leverage and we certainly were
going to fix the whole thing but there
was a hope to maybe call back spending
in a meaningful way and they just gave
up they choked at the 11th hour and I
know that there are a lot of people
saying well you know we didn't have no
you you had a lot of Leverage and at
what point in time do you step up and
and you know say enough's enough the
reality is that the debt has grown
substantially under Republican and
Democratic congresses and their
presidents so there's something baked
into the big government system that's at
issue and I would love to see more
right-of-center people standing up and
really taking issue and addressing these
things there are a couple really easy
things that they could do that would
start to put us on the path and and
things that would protect the wealth
talk about you you will owe nothing of
the younger generation I mean we're
fighting over student debt repayment how
about just restructuring that system so
that the government's no longer the
biggest predatory lender in the country
and they stop transferring wealth from
teenagers to colleges and their
administrators like where's the where
are the Republican candidates saying
like day one I'm gonna get the
government out of student lending and
bring back underwriting and bring back
bankruptcy and have colleges have skin
in the game like that's that's an easy
win right or how about the politicians
saying hey maybe you don't need a
useless four-year degree and there's
plenty of other things you could do like
trade schools or apprenticeships or or
whatever it might be we still put this
emphasis on you know these universities
where you basically get a degree in
lesbian dance Theory and then you wonder
why you're not a neuroscientist
um let's talk about the coins Bitcoin
and centralized coins for a little bit
because it does seem now that uh you
know the governments that the United
States government's looking into it
certainly the world economic Forum all
of these big governments are looking
into now centralized coins as opposed to
decentralized coins which was the whole
point of Bitcoin that there would be
nobody in between you and the person you
were exchanging goods with and you could
do it all in a decentralized meaning no
one could take it away or stop you from
doing it manner that seems to now be
going in the other direction thanks to
all of this
yeah I mean is there any scarier threat
to power to the fed and the government
than people being able to transact and
not relying on them I mean that that's a
huge threat so basically we have a very
financially illiterate population so
it's very easy for them to conflate
issues I mean this is a sad you know
situation but that's just the truth so
because there's so much interest in
Bitcoin
um and other cryptocurrency and the fact
that there has been so many issues not
with the currencies the the
cryptocurrencies themselves but with
things around the periphery the
infrastructure things like the exchanges
FTX and there's been a lot of fraud that
they're they're basically seizing on
that and they're saying well you don't
want you know those guys to control what
you're doing you want the good old
government and the FED because we've
really done such a banner job in keeping
the dollar stable you know you want us
in control right and to be clear you
don't even need the exchanges right you
don't need FTX you don't need coinbase
or anything else you can do this all
peer-to-peer one to one but that's sort
of a separate topic but people just
don't understand yeah
they're basically saying we're going to
create our own dish digital currency but
as you mentioned this would be entirely
centralized and it would be under the
purview of the FED in the government to
the point where they could basically
track every single digital dollar that
you have and everything that you spend
it on and again not conspiratorial the
New York fed along with 12 different
financial institutions ran a pilot
program and they put out their findings
at the wholesale level saying this is
great we had the G7 come out with their
principles for retail facing cbdc so
these are not things that you do if
you're not thinking about it at all the
concern is is that they're going to hook
people in again but with this bait and
switch hey Dave I'm going to give you a
hundred digital dollars if you just give
up that one dollar and then you're gonna
go well that's a terrible idea but you
know there are people who are going to
go oh my God I'm Gonna Be A Millionaire
this is going to be great and it goes
back to that Saturday Night Live skit
which I reference in the book with Dan
Aykroyd is Jimmy Carter when they
actually talked about things like
monetary policy and going wouldn't you
like to drive a hundred thousand dollar
car and wear a fifty thousand dollar
suit hey everyone's Gonna Be A
Millionaire not realizing that we're
gonna destroy the purchasing power and
have hyperinflation or speaking of
inflation they could say well you know
if you give us a digital currency we can
really control inflation people not
realizing that that means when they say
they're going to destroy demand instead
of just changing interest rates they
actually turn off your currency and you
can't spend it at all so these are the
kinds of things and as you said in the
book we go through you know 10 different
chapters all with kind of a different
theme that you need to be aware of so
that you can really plan and make sure
that you fight back all right so as I
said I want to get to some of the
solution stuff but can you combine ESG
and what we just talked about with the
with the sort of centralized coin and
social credit to sort of what's
happening in China right now let's say
and how that could end up happening here
how they could literally be tracking
your behavior and the people that you
relate with and who you hang out with
how that could then literally affect say
your ability to have a bank account and
maybe if you're a trucker in Canada
instead of them having to call the bank
they can just swipe on an iPad and
they've got all your cash
yes so here we have cancel culture that
morphed into sort of informal social
credit that is one step away from
state-sponsored social credit but think
about what happened during the pandemic
you know if you were somebody who was on
the wrong side of things and you know
you weren't following the the
prescription from the powers that be you
know they were coming after your social
standing they wouldn't let you
participate in society you couldn't go
into a restaurant you weren't wearing a
mask they would take a picture they're
going to send it to your employer in
some cases they shut down your business
like you said the freedom Convoy they
actually took their bank accounts and
froze them for a period of time
um so we see that this is not just about
you know kind of going after your speech
and your compliance but really it is
your financial wherewithal it's your
social standing it's your ability to get
opportunities it's your income which is
the money that you have to be able to
invest and in some cases it's your
actual assets and you know when this
happens in China there's sort of two
components and I would would argue we
would have have both of them one of them
is the technology to be able to collect
and analyze data at scale which we
certainly have and then the social
buy-in and the Chinese Communist party
you know it's done by by force and
threat but here basically there are
people who get what I like to call Roe
or return on ego for participating right
you get to have your your emoji you get
to have you know maybe get a visit to
the White House you got to wear the
t-shirt and you're considered part of
the good crowd they've taken it to a
different level in China and you know
where we have sort of ESG and social
credit separate things it's basically
the same thing there and they actually
went after the businesses first because
they knew if they could make sure that
those people didn't get too big and
weren't too out of lines and went after
their financial wherewithal it's much
easier to get the individual population
to fall in line but they have crazy
things I mean there's a story
um from NPR about a gentleman by the
name of loud Juwan who was a coal
intermediary and he basically by bought
and sold coal and stored it in the
meantime well the Chinese government
changed their policy on coal and all of
a sudden the coal is now worthless and
he's bankrupt well that's a bad thing
and you have to go on The Blacklist even
though it was the government's fault
with this policy change so he goes out
and he looks at this billboard and he
sees his face and he's got his name and
his personal identification number and
it says this is an untrustworthy person
and as he as they're changing you know
right out of an Orwell movie as they're
changing he's seeing other people from
the coal industry that he recognizes
that all had been Fallen the same fate
so it may seem like we're far away from
that but really you know how far away
from that are we when we have you know
the government who's colluding with
social media and you have them doing
executive orders to take your jobs away
from you and they're shutting down
businesses this is all really becoming
very formalized whether is that the
individual social credit level or at
that ESG number level
and then like you said let's see and
then with CMB cbdc right then you know
obviously then you have the the currency
that can control your compliance please
tell me that you've seen the episode of
black mirror right
I have a good Twilight Zone episode in
the book I'm very old school I'm a
little bit I'm a little bit on the older
side Dave oh listen there is an episode
with uh what's his name Howard price
Dallas Howard from Jurassic Park all
about the social cry I think it won an
Emmy is all about the social credit
score and what the how dark and twisted
the future will be but just in our
remaining time we've painted a pretty
bleak picture here we don't want to be
trying to help us help the people feel
good about the about all of this
yeah so after you understand each of
these things you really have to come up
with a plan to fight back individually
and the good news is for people who are
a little worried about this
um it's the same kind of good Financial
advice that you should probably be doing
anyway but it just puts it in a
different lens so things like hard
assets you know as we're talking about
this concept of ownership you know don't
be just spending on frivolous things
really be thinking about that level of
ownership and one of the things that you
said earlier about sort of the you know
what it is that they're saying and what
they're doing at the elite level like
that's one of the key things like what
is it that the elite are doing not what
they're saying but what are they doing
you know they're buying up tons of
productive land you know the essential
banks are investing in gold and other
precious metals so certainly you may not
be able to do it on the same scale yet
but if we had a cbdc wouldn't it be
great whether you're a crypto person or
a hard asset precious metal person to
have maybe you have both a diversified
portfolio and have some things that you
could barter with in case there's a
period of chaos where we were underneath
a system like this
um definitely like if you don't own a
home own a home and I know that the
mortgages are really expensive right now
and it may mean that you have to go to a
different location where it's a little
less expensive but you don't want to be
giving that money that you earn over to
a wall Streeter who wants to rent you
back the American dream and I'm sure we
could talk for hours on this but also
estate planning you know there's almost
85 trillion dollars that is set to turn
over voluntarily in this country in the
next 23 years we've heard things about
non-realized capital gains taxes and you
know wealth and they always put the
carrot out there they're just going to
go after the billionaires just like
those 87 000 new IRS staff are going
after the 800 billionaires right so you
have to not concede your principles
because once you do they're going to
come after you and having some estate
planning may or may not but it's worth a
try grandfather you in to you know some
of these things that could come down the
pike you know on a personal note because
people ask me all the time I think the
one really Smart Financial thing that
I've done is very much in line with what
you just said which is I've owned three
houses and each one of them was a
stretch I stretched as far as I could
and fortunately timing was right
interest rates were low I did really
well on each one each one pushed me to a
new level financially and and now I
ended up in a state that also has no
income tax which is nice but I for me if
you if you buy physical things whether
that's land or a house or something
physical I know that's not the only way
to do it and you want the Diversified
portfolio that you're talking about like
I always feel like when I'm paying my
mortgage now I'm like I know I'm paying
some interest but I feel like in essence
I'm paying myself now when interest
rates hit six seven percent it's a
little bit different but but everyone
kind of has to figure that out for
themselves I suppose
yeah everybody has sort of a different
Financial background and you know
different risk profiles so you want to
talk to an advisor if you can to make
sure that that it's right for you but it
really is a change in mindset I mean the
funny thing is with this book I have so
many people who are actually buying the
physical hard copies instead of Kindle
or audiobook just as a behavioral shift
if you just have this awareness of like
oh you know is this a subscription do I
own something what happens if they cut
me off it's just a different way to go
through life and it's not being a
prepper people say like yo you sound
like a prepper being a prepper is living
that lifestyle every single day which
again is fine if that's what you want to
do but being prepared is meant to take
the burden off of you right you think
about it in the moment and then you can
enjoy life because that's what it's
about you don't want to have these
burdens hanging over you so I believe
that everybody can make these small
Financial behavioral changes and
hopefully you know the elite may want
you to own nothing but I want you to own
everything so you know make sure you go
out and start owning things and I
proudly own a copy of the book you will
own nothing so if I have one thing it is
the book the link is right down below
Carol it was a pleasure finally chatting
with you yes thanks so much Dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell